is Chloe Grace Moretz British no but
funny enough I did fool Martin Scorsese
into thinking that I was I had
auditioned for a movie called Hugo cabre
and he was only going to hire British
girl and I was like yeah I can do that
so I went into the audition and I fully
pretended to be from England and that my
parents wore horse breeders and that we
lived in the Cotswolds I had a whole
whole big lie a huge lie and then I
booked the part and it was like a month
into production that he was like wait
are you just doing an American accent
and I was like no I'm like American like
my accent is Southern naturally if I
don't iron it out I guess maybe I am
British so
depends if I believe my own life